king or sultan
there was one king there was one sultan
and then there were millions of
peasants or in a feudal society so if
you view yourself as the king or the or
the sultan have at it have all have a
harem of women but most men at least
back in the day were lucky even in the
old testament so there's go ahead hug me
in the old testament so here's here's
here's what he's butchering and andrew i
love you but let me let me clarify terms
here because again taking work the red
pill work and then applying it like
andrew does or kevin or whoever else
this is a prime example of this when i
talk about this i actually pulled this
from well i wrote about it in the fourth
book but i pull it from a book called
alpha god which is another thing i think
you should probably read at some point
it's by dr hector garcia fascinating
book
and so in there uh dr hector garcia
points out that there are three things
that have defined powerful men
throughout the course of history that is
territory that is resources and that is
access to virginic beautiful women that
they have exclusive access to so you can
go around the world in any any era and
that is the case so there's the tribal
chieftain that's in the amazon
rainforest and he's got his his his hose
in in a in a a compound or he's got him
you know fenced off somewhere and
they're guarded by eunuchs they got to
cut off their dick so that they know
that though
that's the the chieftains uh you know
that's his brood that's his his harem to
make sure that his genetics go on into
perpetuity and this is in civilization
with kings and queens same thing with
with uh uh you know dynastic emperors of
china and the forbidden city guarded by
eunuchs they've got you know the harem
of women that are there okay the things
that and by or we're using extreme
examples and he's using extreme examples
for effect but the fact of the matter is
is that powerful men throughout his
father abraham right he's got what he
had sarah and he had uh was it uh wasn't
ruth was it was i forget that the two
wives he had hair plus plus he had made
servant scottish you know i know that
brother that's a great show was the
other one rachel rachel was the other
one so anyway i don't know
what but it was
we can talk about i'm not a theologian
or a biblical scholar by any means but i
will say this is that like there are
sections of the bible where marriage is
defined in a whole lot of different ways
we only think of marriage between one
man and one woman in the new testament
prior to that there's all kinds of
different definitions for marriage but
the point i'm making is that there's you
can find polygamy examples of polygamy
exactly what he's talking about and the
powerful man the powerful chieftain in
the old testament you can find it in in
the quran you can find it all throughout
history so that's what he's kind of
butchering a little bit right there
thinking well i'm a powerful man so
therefore i should be able to have a her
harim i always mispronounce that right
but that's the that's the point he's
trying to make for effect but he's not
wrong because by order of degree we
still practice soft polygamy right now
if you've been you've been married once
before and if those were the only people
you would still have two two wives at
some point assuming you get married
again but i presume that you've already
had sex with other women as well so
there's like this idea that men are men
by order of degree
will uh will will form soft harems if
that's marrying multiple women then
that's another thing but again it's by
your powerfulness and sort of that
dominance hierarchy amongst men so is
that the right way is that the wrong way
what i'm saying is i don't say right and
wrong but i will say this is that men's
innate native natural mating strategy is
unlimited access to unlimited women and
for women it is hypergamy it is alpha
[ __ ] and beta bucks they're looking for
quality men are looking for the quantity
side of things and if you don't believe
me i'll just present one fact to you why
do you think so many men are addicted to
porn why do you think that pornography
is free 4k streaming ubiquitous i can go
look at porn right now if you want to
but you condemn porn though you don't
think i think porn is sedation okay okay
so sedation for what sedation to keep
you is to keep you from becoming your fl
to keep men from realizing their full
potential and by the way it's one of
many so just saying just like just like
food can be sedation just like alcohol
prescription
here's my question about tate weed um
i'm not saying whether you like him or
don't like him or agree or disagree i'm
asking
percentage-wise
what percentage of men even men in
america can operate the way that he's
operating oh very small percentage what
number point
one percent okay
i think i would even go a fraction of
one percent but i agree and that's my
point is that tate god bless you bro
[ __ ] play on player i do your thing i
you're hilarious to watch but
the problem that i have is that you
watching this at home the the the young
guy who's watching him being like i'm
going to be like tate no you're not yeah
it's it's it's it's not happening it's
iceberg slim all over again it's it's
literally the pimp the pimp from you
know the 1940s being uh popularized in
culture although do you respect the
hustle do i respect the entrepreneurial
side of things yeah i respect it but i
think i don't resp i don't i don't think
it's as hard to do that versus other
things we talked about this so there's a
famous quote what don't hate the player
hate the game buddy that's fair you're
hating the game right now listen listen
but what i'm going to say is yeah what i
said last time lust of the eyes less of
the flesh pride of life those are always
going to be the easier things to sell so
but much more difficult rollo to do what
you do in trying to write books and sell
books than it is to to sell a lifestyle
or to sell cam girls or to do only fans
so i don't i think we have to be fair in
that yes
is he brilliant in terms of his mind and
the way he's thinking chess master all
that sure is what he's selling that
tough of a commodity to sell no it's not
a lot of people sell it what was the the
young lady that was here i was here last
time
you know uh a hundred thousand a month
eight hundred thousand whatever the
number was right yeah right and so it's
like do i respect the husband the loss
of the eyes less of less than the flesh
yeah
um i'll add something else to that i
would say that fear is the most
monetizable of the human emotions
um fear of missing out fomo you're
talking about
yeah
what is it uh uh uh freedom fear and
selem security you talked about kevin
samuels do you think that he's uh filled
the void that kevin samuel i think he
stepped him right into that vacuum and i
think the tough part is what is this
entertainment or is this is this science
right i think that's the very fact that
you're asking that question is exactly
right
and i guess that's the to me that's the
dangerous part because we can't tell if
these guys playing a character if he's
just if he's being a wwe character
that's you sean michaels but that's not
really you you're kind of amplifying it
or if this is who he really is i think
that's a tough part and i think young
men get very confused just like we saw
gangster rap music in the early 90s a
lot of young men didn't know that dr dre
wasn't really out there
in the streets gang banging right i
think people can't tell the difference
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]